hey babe
hey what are you doing
ladies and gentlemen welcome to
another episode of
your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
all right we did it
[Laughter]
um yeah i had to turn it off i mean it i
mean it just it just
is what it is i mean i am in new york
right now so
like i got my computer right here i'm
trying to do this i'm just i'm just
i'm just trying to do my podcast as best
i can
um it's
i mean listen when you're a one-man show
that this is you know this is how it
goes but i'm here
welcome to riffing with griffin from
excuse me welcome to wifi griffin uh
from new york city
live from new york city i got my little
mic that i record cause that
i mean you guys don't even know what's
going on so i had to record this cartoon
that i'm doing
this is hbo max cartoon called 10 year
old tom
that should become an hbo max sometime
next year i think i don't even know
because a cartoon process
so so i have my mic for that because i
had to record from the hotel room
the damn internet in this hotel is
terrible
okay oh speaking of oh my god it's going
to take me forever to upload my pod
upload this podcast as i'm thinking
about it right now with this hotel
internet
let me not even think about it right now
so and then like you know i got this
weird light there's no good lights in
the hotel so i got this weird
light so i got to do the podcast before
the light you know sun goes down because
then i won't even be able to do the
podcast i know it looks
the way it looks if you're watching it
but if you're listening i guess it
sounds fun cause i still got
my logic set up and all that kind of
stuff so just uh
excuse me just trying to make it happen
but
i'm here in new york uh let me just tell
you all about it i'm staying in brooklyn
so you know i booked this movie um
this ray romano movie he's like
the star and he's he wrote it with his
partner and
they've been working on it for like six
years and he's finally making it
so it's like i'm in it sebastian
montescalco's in it you know it's great
you know so i got the part flew out to
new york
had to quarantine because i i got my
second shot
i got my second shot um
the sunday like last sunday
and so then i had to get here on tuesday
because by the
sag or whatever rules you have to like
quarantine for four days in your hotel
before you could start working so i came
and i did that
and so you know here i am um
i'm just look i keep looking over at the
computer because i don't know what is
happening
i don't know if this is gonna work right
but you know we're gonna we're gonna
make the best of this
we're going to do you know we're going
to do what we need to do
[Laughter]
okay so anyways i'm looking everything
seems to be fine so
yeah so you have to quarantine for four
days and whatnot
and so here we are so i got to you know
get to new york okay whatever so i just
want to tell you some things that have
happened it's just it's just great
experience so i'm just going to like
relay what has been going on because
this podcast is about me
i guess right you got the the the few of
you that want to like that like to
listen every week i appreciate you and
so here we are
by the way i even tried to stream so i
brought my xbox you know what i mean i
don't got my good camera so i'm using my
little webcam camera to do this right
now but i just want to keep i got
you know i have i feel like i have a
responsibility to put out my podcast
regardless of whatever
and it's just hard to do all this by
yourself when you travel you have to
rely on the hotel internet and all that
kind of stuff so
but i brought my xbox to stream and i'm
still trying to stream daily
on eric griffin gaming so check that out
on twitch
so anyways so i get to new york so i'm
quarantined for four days
oh man it's terrible it's hard to be
like you know when you feel
you're not at home it's just about not
being at home and this hotel is nice but
it's still just
one room and it's like at this like
cement floor it's like one of these
artsy fartsy hotels
you know that you know it's like i i
don't like staying at artsy fartsy
hotels like boutique
i want to stay someplace just if i'm
here for two weeks it should have a
refrigerator that's empty i don't need a
mini bar
what i'm gonna be drinking every day i
don't even drink refrigerator that's
empty it should have a microwave in
there
for an extended stay type place the
hotel in the
the restaurant in this hotel super
expensive everything's like 30
okay so it's like damn whatever little
money i'm making on this movie i gotta
spend it on the food to be here
but anyways so i'm making the best of it
trying to talk to rachel every day you
know i'm catching up on shows
and stuff like that so you know that
that that is what it is
but let me just tell you something
happened last night excuse me i don't
know why i'm coughing so much stupid
so so you know i'm just randomly and i
get this phone call
you know and i don't answer because i
said no id
and uh funny sidetrack story on that my
buddy
gerard carmichael you know i don't know
if you guys know gerard carmichael jamal
he's like this great young comic
producer writer
director he's just like one of those it
guys you know he's like one of the
hollywood it guys he was young they
pegged him now he's got hbo shows he's
produced movies he produces shows for
people
he's just one of these insider hollywood
guys he hangs out with jay-z
you know what i mean he's like he you
know he just he has like this fabulous
life of jerrod carmichael should be the
documentary
but he would never do a documentary
because he's too damn pretentious to do
a documentary right
so i love him though he's just he's just
like one of my best friends
okay but anyways he calls and
it's caller id block now you know what i
mean he's the kind of guy he changed his
number like all the time he don't want
people to have his number right so he'll
change his number but he don't
you know he has the id block no matter
who he calls
so i didn't answer the call i don't like
answering no id calls
and then he says to me he goes hey man
when he finally gets me on the phone
he's like
you got to answer the phone when you see
nobody you don't know who it is it could
be oprah for all you know i'm like oprah
ain't calling me but that's his life
because that's his life is you know
he said to him he said to me what jay-z
called me
and i didn't know i i didn't know until
i saw him a month later and he was like
yo man i tried to call you
so he's telling me like you gotta answer
the phone when there's no id
because you never know who was calling
you but like that's not gonna happen to
me
right i think like that ain't gonna
happen to me you know so for you
you the young it kid you know you live
in a fabulous life nobody gonna be
calling me like that
well sure enough ray romano calls me
it's no idea i don't answer then i get a
text message hey you know he's directing
the movie so i expect to like
talk to him but it still was like
shocking so he like he calls me
i don't answer you know and then he
gives me like a call i see the text
message he goes hey this is ray romano
eric
give me a call back i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm
streaming at the time and i go i gotta
go
you know because listen for me
this is like a huge honor even just to
be in this movie for them to pick me for
the movie i was like okay great
but even still it's like you know i'm a
comic that came up in the era where
these type of comedy icons
were huge this is what tv shows were
made of they don't even do it anymore
where they take like
a comic who's been around you know he
has this solid act
about his life and they turn it into a
sitcom you know
they just don't do that anymore but it
was like kevin james
ray romano tim allen seinfeld
these were the people they did that for
and that was like so when i was coming
up that was always going to be my dream
i saw i have the show where i was you
know what you know
because you followed these guys so
anyway for me it's a huge honor
and i'm really excited to like you know
so i call him he answers and he's you
know and his
his voice is so distinct
it was just like i was geeking out i
didn't even want to tell him
i'm geeking out because i'm like oh damn
this this is actually ray romano on my
phone this everybody loves raymond i
i hear his voice you know it was like it
was really like a moment for me
so then you know he says
thanks for being in the movie he tells
me a little bit about what we're gonna
do
for the this crazy part i'm playing and
i'm like all right cool whatever you
want you know what i mean like i'm not
trying to
i'm like whatever you want bro so
and then he goes listen my writer
and then the guy just playing my best
friend they're in the hotel with you
also they're about to get ready get in
the car
come get me to come to the city and
we're gonna go get some pizza
i want you want to come i'm like yo you
want to hang out
yeah bro you know this is in my head i'm
thinking so you know trying to be cool
like well you know
i guess you know i'm just sitting here
you know
trying to play it off right but i'm like
yeah i'm already grabbing my clothes
while i'm talking to him on the phone
thinking like
i you know then i was like oh thank god
i brought my good shirt
so i had this one shirt to bring because
i was like you never know when you go
out so i was like
get my good shirt so i even tell rachel
i hit her up like oh my god you'll never
guess what's happening
i got i'm so glad i got my good shirt so
i get my shirt
you know and then we uh i you know we
actually get out there
you know he gets in the car with us
later we get me park and then we start
walking to this pizza place but he's
just like just
just straight up normal dude you know
and so then he just starts talking to me
you know what i mean and it's just like
i was like all right you know like i'd
known him forever
and we went to this great piece of
plates i think it was called joey's
there's probably like 100 joey's in new
york
you know he's like this is the best
pizza in new york it's world famous this
kind of thing you always hear this
like sometimes i get sick of hearing
about new york pizza like how good it is
because i've had so many times i've come
to new york and i've been like this
piece of
eye you know what i mean like it's just
a height
like there's like i don't like what's
the difference then people say well
it's the new york water when they make
the bread dough and like
just all kinds of nonsense and just as a
person is i've world traveled i've been
all over the world okay and if you
brought me pizza from
all the different places i've been i
wouldn't be like oh that's the one
i think it just depends on the place
right to their credit this pizza was
actually really good
it was really good so we had pizza and
then we're just
shooting the [ __ ] talking about stuff
and then afterwards
by the way he says hey then we're going
to go down to caroline's now like i've
never performed at caroline's
i've met the lady that books it many
times and she's like the mitzi of the
east coast
okay everybody knows her you know
the caroline's is the comedy store of
the east coast and
and comedy stores the carolines of the
west coast you know it's that kind of
thing it's
two like iconic places for comedy
i've never performed there before you
know i've tried to get in and it's like
like i remember meeting her i was in new
york one time
and i was chilling with my buddy godfrey
we went over to caroline's and we're
just chilling and we're sitting with her
and we're talking
and i wasn't i wasn't trying to like you
know whatever you know and i just think
that i was just being chill and cool and
she was like all right why don't you
text me
he sent me an email you know so so then
i was going to new york to do something
else and i tried to email her
nothing what's your credits you know and
i was like oh no i hate that question so
but i sent a thing didn't hear from her
nothing
so i was like i guess i just won't be in
at caroline's right
so cut two now i'm walking in with ray
romano
who started at caroline's right and it's
like
you you know you feel like you're part
of a like a mob
like like you know like you're walking
in with john gotti
you know and like everybody's like you
know it's that kind of thing uh
like that scene from goodfellas where
ray leota walks in and he's you know he
put a table right here you know they
just put a table like
everybody else has to move out of the
way because you know that's how it felt
people just walking in you know we
walking in with them you know
and listen i'm not famous i don't think
i'm famous
at all but in the comedy world
i think i'm i think i'm famous enough
if you're in the comedy scene that if
you saw me you you'd be like
oh that's that dude you know you know
what i mean like in the comedy scene
you know it's like workaholics
especially i'm dying up here
um you know i just booked that pilot
that's the kind of thing comedy people
are like
oh that's that dude i was in murder
mystery you know what i mean like i
think if you in the comedy scene
you know i think i'm i'm i'm
recognizable enough to
the comedian world where you like oh
that's that's that's eric griffin or
that's
the dude from whatever whatever you want
to say right so
the door guy and i see the recognition
on people's faces like
okay he hanging out with ray romano all
right that's that you know whatever
you know so then we're going to get
spots and ray's like yeah
eric go up you know so then we see the
lady etsy as her name
you know she's like so excited to see
ray and oh my god you know
and he looks over to me goes yeah this
is eric griffin you know and she's like
huh
and then i put my mask down you know
nobody was really wearing a mask at this
point you know
but you know some people were you know
she's like oh yeah you know
i know she didn't know who the hell i
was
it was just one of those moments man she
didn't know who the hell i was but she
was like oh yeah
oh good to see you it gives me a little
half hug and i'm just like
hilarious you know what i mean but i get
it i'm not mad about it it's just
it's just it was just one of those
moments where
you know you have to wait you wait for
these kind of moments you know what i
mean
you wait for these kind of moments like
it's like like
you get in on your own merits you get or
you get it like however you think the
right way to do it
but in a roundabout way i had to bust my
ass for like 18 years now
to get into a position where a guy like
ray romano's walking me in
i'm not a guy off the street i i i'm
funny enough to be in that club you know
what i mean
um i don't care if you agree or not
actually i'm telling you i'm funny
enough to be in that club you know what
i'm saying
like like i i've i've earned my
my stripes in this damn business so but
through all that roundabout way it still
had to be done like
this but i earned my right to be
standing with him in the first place to
be walking in so it's like a weird like
the brotherhood of comedians is it in in
in the
how it all works is really strange you
know it's a strange but like i get it
so you know then
we go and we do sets you know what i
mean i go up into a set i see my boy
dean edwards is there
and we and we actually we're bumping him
and
and i'm already feeling uncomfortable
because i know ray romano's walking in
he's like yeah um
i'm gonna go next you know and i i hate
that by the way
it's like you know you coming just call
and be like put him on the list
but i get it after 30 years you've
earned the right to
to do that and i'm with him so by
default
you know i'm coming in but she asked
dean
you know he told me this later hey is it
okay you know and he was like cool
and then when he saw me we go back so i
think he was like all right that's my
boy eric so
i'm cool with this it's not a slight on
him
and so i do my first set at caroline's i
was a little nervous
but i thought it went and i'm and i
haven't performed enough you know comedy
because of quarantine because of
covet but i still think i did my thing
and you know when the guy announced me
oh eric griffin there's a lot of people
in the crowd that were like oh
it's just you know and i'm like all
right yeah
did my set it was cool so then he's
telling me later
that he does his set he's fun we go to
another room he does his set and he's
still got it he's just a funny dude man
ray romano you know and his daughter's
in the crowd you know what i mean
um so we do that
and then you know so then he's talking
about well we should come on the weekend
cause we're gonna be here for two weeks
you know and i say to him well this is
what i say to him i go how about
we tell her we're gonna come so she
could put us on the list so we not
bumping anybody
you know like i i say that to him and
he's like you know all right good idea
you know so he says to the lady
we want to come in the weekend and she's
like well can you tell me right now
cause she makes the list and it's like a
really you know what i mean
so then i then then i'm communicating
with her now because she's like
i need to put you in our database and
boom boom so i was like oh [ __ ] does
that mean i'm in
i don't know but like we're going to
perform on saturday and he might cancel
but i'm still going to go
right i mean because i just feel like
yeah be in at this iconic club
you know what i mean don't burn any
bridges you know
so but let me go back
so like you know when we were talking
this is what i'm saying about ray romano
he's such a
i mean there's like an old school vibe
that these guys
that started 30 years ago that some of
them have
that you can so he's telling me about
how he does stand up now and he's like
yeah well he usually does a mirage
like how he does stand up and how i do
stand up is completely different
his stand-up is an event like he's in
vegas at the mirage and people are
actually flying to vegas like they're
tailgating like let me go see ray romano
yeah let's go to vegas and go watch ray
romano
you know or even people that are in
vegas are like oh man ray romano's here
let's go pay that 75
ticket or however much it is you know so
they go
you know so he's telling me about it he
goes you know he's like yeah we
it's great you know we usually we go in
on a thursday we he's like i golf i do
this
i do that you know and then like you
know after the show
and then he has this moment where he
doesn't want to he doesn't want to say
like he's being super humble and casual
about it but he's like ah you know
and then we like you know we fly home on
you know on a private jet just the way
he said it i was like
i said dude don't apologize
because you you know what i mean don't
apologize because you're flying home on
a private jet you know it's just like
don't feel bad about it it was just a
little thing i was like don't feel bad
you worked
you busted your ass for 30 years to be
an iconic comedian
personality so you could fly private you
know what i mean like i just
i totally get it it just was like a cool
moment but you know
but i really felt the camaraderie and he
took to me in his old school buddy just
playing his
best friend in the movies there and he
was actually on a dino pier uh what is
that guy's name
listen i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
whatever okay cool dude
but he's old crotchety you know and they
started together
like he actually put ray on he actually
got ray in at the club
back 30 years ago you know that kind of
d yes he's that kind of guy so he's just
like you know
cool ass dude but there was this sort of
comedian camaraderie
and i knew exactly what it was and
there it is a brotherhood that i can't
explain and i'm gonna attempt to
you know when you're a comedian like
that so
you know i i really felt like ray took
to me you know what i mean like he like
in a sense of like he was like
he talked about comedy he was you know
interested in like things and we were
and we had this sort of thing where it's
like and what is and where does that
come from you know
i just think it comes from like when you
have that shared experience of like
the struggle of comedy or knowing the
things you have to do to get to a
certain level
all comedians share that and
of course the ones that are on a higher
level they share an experience
with each other too i'm sure when
chappelle and chris rock and these kind
of guys are hanging out
they got a shared experience of like
what it took to be
that iconic but they have that
and they can be around people who are
lesser than them
in terms of their comedian comedic
stature because they know even what it
took to get to that point
and there is this sort of camaraderie
you know i've seen it when like
when chris rock was around the comedy
store you know
my brief interactions with him he still
has even though he's an
odd dude he's still got that there's
that thing
now the problem is it's not everybody
like too many comics that are just
coming up they think because they've
labeled themself a comic
that they understand and they think
they're like
you know they think that well listen
like i'm an intern like no
until you've it's like if someone told
me
like back in the day if it was like yeah
i'm passed
at the comedy store if somebody told me
that
and i didn't even know them per se yet
let's say
or i hadn't been around let's say i was
off in australia filming a movie for a
year
i don't know whatever i'm just saying
and somebody says to me oh yeah man i
just got passed at the comment store
back in the day
you know what it took to do that you
know all the steps you had to take
you know how tough that was the road to
the travel to get to the point where you
were considered a regular at that club
so that's a shared experience and that
brotherhood that's where the brotherhood
is
you know and it's like it's not about
necessary success levels so much as like
understanding that process it took to
get to that point
in the business so even now you know
people are like you know i i
i got on a show or you know
and it's not you know you you've seen
this person around for a long time and
they're like oh you oh you know what it
takes it's like all the
auditioning and the testing process and
getting an agent and all that stuff
sometimes you know that's the
brotherhood of
just recognizing the struggle and
achieving that
overcoming that you know and then also
like
you know if somebody watches you and
they think they're fun you're funny or
they appreciate your art form
you know it's like oh i like how you
constructed this or that you know it's
that
it takes time it's time to be a part of
that truly be a part of that brotherhood
and to me there's just too many people
who are like just starting out
and even if they think they have a
little bit of success they think that
that they're
they're entitled to that same level of
understanding and respect from people
and it just i don't know
it just doesn't work there's no right or
wrong way there's no right or wrong
steps but it just it's an it's a thing
you just know i wish i can
express it better i wish i was able to
explain to you guys
how i feel about this but it's just man
i don't know hey guys i want to talk to
you guys once again about my great
sponsor
betterhelp and you can go to
betterhelphelp.com
griffin griffin betterhelp.com griffin
uh
great sponsor of the show and it's one
of my favorite sponsors just because
you know i do real well advice from a
grown-ass man and i often say
hey i'm not an expert so i encourage
people to go get help and get some
therapy and and this is
it because there's uh many things that
interfere with our happiness and
many things that interfere with making
sure that we're living our best
living our best life and our best selves
and you know come on in this day and age
with covet and
job worries and money worries and
relationship worries
you know you need some help so i
encourage you to reach out you know you
connect in a safe and private
environment
it's really super convenient you can
start communicating with someone in
under 48 hours i
myself have gone to therapy and i loved
it it really
it was uncomfortable but it helped me
organize my thoughts and really pinpoint
like oh
this is why i have for me it was
boundary issues
you know letting people take advantage
of me and i really went and talked about
it and worked through it and i'm still
working on it
it's a work in progress but they have
licensed professional counselors who are
specializing in
all the things you can think of guys
depression
depression stress anxiety relationships
lgbt
matters self-esteem family conflicts
anything you can think of
please guys it's confidential it's not
self-help these are licensed
professionals in fact so many people
have been using better help
that they are recruiting additional
counselors in all
50 states so you got to be a part of
this
i want you to start living a happier
life today
as a listener you'll get 10 percent off
your first month by visiting your our
sponsor
betterhelp.com griffin and that's
betterhelp
h-e-l-p-betterhelp.com
griffin join over one million people who
have taken
charge of their mental health and that's
better help
help dot com slash griffin for 10
off your first month
i want i appreciate you guys being here
take charge of your happiness let's get
back to so and i remember when i was
doing a dying up here and i remember
meeting jim carrey
who is like the oddest dude he's just an
odd guy man
so odd um because it's like
think of being that famous for that long
that wealthy you know i don't even know
if you even interact with regular people
anymore and then he had that big beard
and he just was like dealing with a
court case and all that stuff that was
going on in his life
he just was a weird dude but he was here
but he knew that
to get this show off the ground for the
publicity he was going to have to be at
front and center like we went to the up
fronts and the up fronts are a place
where
it's like a big press junket where
you're there
you're on a panel and they're asking you
questions about the show
and all the press outlets from around
the world or whoever's interested in
this stuff for the cable
up fronts you know they're going to be
like so what do you think about uh
comedy and you know you know doing
comedy in the 70s is it different from
the you know so all these questions
but you have jim carrey sitting up there
every single question was directed at
him i think i answered one question
and then after that it was just so jim
jim jim so
he was right there with it you know but
i remember this moment
but he he he we had this dinner and he
was talking to us about the comedy store
the back in the days and he just was
going in and it was just
fascinating to hear all the stories
about kennison and how he started and he
just
loved it he i could just tell he was
just reminiscing and he was talking to
people especially the comics
me santino al madrigal we were comics
who were at the comedy store
so like for us hearing this history
we understood and i think he was he was
understood that too so anyways my point
is
so we're at the ice house and we're
doing this like party for
i'm dying up here and i know i
remember this moment and i think i've
even told this story but whatever it's
pertinent to this
he uh yeah the press are kind of bugging
him people are like on him
and i look over to him and i say jim
come over here man
you know and he comes over to us and
it's me al magical santino it's just the
comics and some of the actors you know
and when he came over and i can like
really see him like be
comfortable you know because it's like
well we're just doing the comic thing
outside of comedy club
and he's like i don't think he's even i
think i don't think he's done that
in so many years but it just felt like
yeah so he stepped in even though he's
like an icon
you know what i mean like just a giant
in the comedy world
he came with us and it was like i feel
like he felt
comfortable with us and he felt at ease
but he didn't have to be around these
people
that were always asking him for things
because at that level you can't trust
anyone
even us really you know but there's
still that brotherhood connection
and i think he felt and i felt it in
that moment i really did
i really felt it and we took this great
picture at that moment too
you know and our heads were you know hit
side to side it's on my instagram
someplace
i mean this is the point where i would
put it up but like i'm doing this by
myself so sorry you go check my
instagram
and that's eric griffin and you'll see
go scroll way down and you'll see this
picture of me and jim carrey like head
to head
you know and it wasn't until later that
i looked at that picture and i thought
to myself
oh man that's jim carrey you know like
that's
jim carrey and i having like a real
intimate moment you know and he you know
and he's just
i don't know and it's just my
perspective you talk to him he might be
like these idiots you know who knows but
i don't care i'm i'm i believe in fufu
stuff
and i believe that there was some sort
of brotherhood connection there
and again and i feel the same way last
night
hanging out with ray and going to the
comedy store i mean i mean the
um the comedy seller just having this
like real
like moment you know
so i don't know guys
um damn that was dope
it just was like i'm still like thinking
about it like ah that was still cool to
to go to because even people that we
started with
they move on like sebastian sebastian
let's try to see if i can get sebastian
to come on the podcast this week so we
could be on
my next week's episode but who knows i
mean you know but he's like
he's super rich now he's like one of
those guys now he's in the one
percentile of the
the comedian world now you know and even
though we like
i knew him when we were just doing like
shitty gigs and you know
terrible travel gigs overseas you know
you know what i mean and now he's just
like
i barely talk to him you know i don't
even you know what i mean but it's like
we still
but there's that that thing so i don't
even know how that's gonna be
but you know it's just it's just that
kind of thing man
it's like you know you're you're you're
you know this olympic race with all your
comedian buddies and
you know you're not you're racing
against the clock you know are you
racing against each other you're not
really competing with each other but
there is like a level that you know
there's a lot of comics here like
they've been on shows maybe they even
had a special
uh they've been they travel they're
doing good stuff but then there is that
thing that
like propels people forward and they
become a part of this different echelon
and then like
podcasting is like taking people
you know launched people further where
they have this huge
following in there you know they're
doing all this stuff and you're looking
at them like
how we used to look at like seinfeld and
these guys that were doing tv shows now
these big podcast people are like
are are doing that too look what it's
done for people's career or like bert
kreischer and
and tom segura and you know
theo vaughn you know like these people
that are now
they've made themselves so they have
their own little like universe
you know and so i hope that i really
hope that the internet
and how separated everybody is doesn't
really dilute that brotherhood more than
it already is
because now that i think about it i feel
like
sometimes i feel like that's happened i
feel like people aren't disconnected
anymore they're just all in their little
fame bubble
um you know we're not going to clubs and
you know
and i totally get why people don't go to
clubs anymore i totally get why you
don't see
because you want to spend time with your
family or or this
it's just not as important like you see
that like when you go down to the club
to do your 15-minute set at the comedy
store
and that hallway is full of people
hungry
people like you know trying to like
fight to the top
and it's like when you're already in
your career and you're doing things
that sort of becomes not as important
anymore
because you're doing road gigs so if you
want to work on a set
do you have to do it at that place for
that 15 minutes no
you could do it like you go i have to do
an hour so
15 minutes of that hour i'm gonna do is
gonna be me working on new material
and the other 45 minutes is gonna be the
show for the people that paid you know i
mean that's
a different way to do it and then during
the week you spend time with your kids
your family your loved ones
you know organize yourself for the
things that are important i'm starting
to feel like that after this pandemic
you know i'm starting to feel like
what's important to me do i need to go
do comedy every night in la or do i want
to sit on the couch with rachel
or do i want to like you know be at home
and like just
experience that you know so i don't know
i'm at a
i don't know when this is all over how
i'm gonna feel
you know i don't know how i'm gonna feel
so i guess what else
i feel like i'm just rambling in my
hotel room but whatever this is my
podcast this is how i do it
man i do want to talk about this though
like i hate you know psycho once again
some covert news
you know it's like the johnson johnson
vaccine
you know this is so i i feel like they
trying to cancel
the canceling the johnson and johnson
vaccine i really believe like it's an
overreaction
now listen that being said you don't
want anyone to die
okay but there's so many people who are
afraid of vaccines
that they're coming out and they're like
see i knew it so i looked at i was like
okay well how many people
damn johnson johnson vaccine is taking
people out huh
what was it like how many people did 10
000 people die
is it like 100 000 people with some sort
of symptoms like what is it what
what what happened so
you come to find out six
out of seven million people
six again
condolences to those six their families
it's a tragedy but it doesn't mean
that this vaccine should be shut down
i mean it's it's a medication
this ain't vitamin c it's not b12
you know this is a medication that's
concocted in a lab
there's gonna be some stuff just like
peanuts peanuts is a
something that happens in nature i don't
even know a peanuts real or they're
manufactured you know but
either way my point is there's plenty of
people with peanut allergies
there's people who are allergic to
insulin there's people who are allergic
to latex
i mean the human body is a wondrous
machine
and not everything's gonna work with it
but if the odds are
six out of seven million
i don't know if that's enough for for
the panic that everybody feels
i see my like my buddy jamie kennedy
tweeted he's one of those skeptic type
guys he's like you know
he he want to let me see what's going on
with the vaccine so now he's you know he
tweeted this funny thing about like
yeah so all the people that shamed me
for not taking the vaccine i'll accept
your apology something like that right
but i'm thinking to myself bro
six out of seven million
i believe that that thing is pretty safe
you know i mean i have i know
someone personal to me has taken the
johnson johnson
so you know because of all the
media hoopla about it got me a little
bit like oh [ __ ]
should i be worried about this you know
like i'm worried for my loved one i'm
like oh no
and then i had to like shake it off and
be like 6
out of 7 million
i think the way it's being covered i
think the misinformation
about covet from the beginning has just
caused people to like
just go cuckoo man we are cuckoo for
cocoa puffs right now when it comes to
covet
cuckoo for kovit man the cdc is putting
out stuff all i saw a thing in cdc
one like how cove is supposed to be on
surfaces
they're saying yeah one out of ten
thousand that's a thing
they made it seem like in the beginning
they're reporting news like
you're if it was on cardboard on your
amazon packages so you got to be careful
how buddies am i talking about yeah i
leave my packages outside for three days
and
it's like that's some weird
misinformation
who even knows if any of it's true i
mean all the things that the cdc is
coming out with
now that they couldn't come out with
before maybe because trump was in office
or i don't know
like everything is politicized right now
so you don't even know what to believe
but the information they're coming out
with about
you know it's like over 65 it's like 65
percent of the people
uh who died from covet
obesity played a huge factor in it why
are we talking about that
i mean so again you don't know what to
believe
we can't get we can't get information
that we
trust and then you idiots out there
not you but you know what i'm talking
about when i say you who think they're
covet experts especially in the comments
these people are supposedly coveted
experts so they want to say well that's
that you know
it's like i i think we're gonna it's
gonna come out and we're gonna find out
like
a lot of the things that we've been
doing were completely wrong
or it didn't have to be done in the way
that we did it and so but it's we're
never gonna know it's like too late you
know
but anyway i'm just saying like guys
like let's like
don't like calm down i wish people we
could just calm down
use some common sense take the politics
out of it
and just get some medical facts
so and that's the stuff they should be
spreading this
fear-mongering about everything is just
terrible man
it's terrible i mean a lot of people
need the vaccine
and you know by the way i don't even
know if that's true i shouldn't even say
that because who even knows
at this point right now but because then
i
you know you find out the people the
pfizer you know cause i took the pfizer
vaccine i have two
my two shots now they're talking about
well you might have to take it every
year
i was like what now we're
what man if you're if you're a
conspiracy theorist
you start going down a black hole
thinking about that
you know what i mean so i don't know
oh man it's uh
just try to get it as informed as
possible i like watching bill maher's
show even though he gets in trouble all
that i mean
anytime somebody anytime somebody is
open to both sides of an argument
anytime somebody gives voice to
the other side per se quote-unquote the
other side
those people get criticized and i like
joe rogan joe rogan the kind of guy he
gives voice to like
people that have a different opinion
than like especially the liberal
side the progressive liberal you know
these are the people that think they're
they're they're for people even though
they come it's like just like christians
just like christians who hate gays it
seems to be
counter counterproductive it seems to be
against
what you believe in if you believe that
you know everything's about love
and god loves us all and all these
things and then you want to hate
people you're not being real to yourself
that's a lot of liberals are like that
when it comes to like what they they
think they're for people but
you know but only when they agree with
that
so joe rogan is the type of guy he puts
people on his podcast but the other side
is like oh i can't believe you're
giving voice to this other side that's
like okay
what so bill maher is like that too you
know
so he gets in he gets in so then his
voice gets
muted because you know people think oh
well
you know you know he gave voice to
such and such or he's criticizing the
liberals so once you criticize liberals
now you're you're the devil
you know but i love watching this show
because you know
he has a lot of you know he puts good
information out there
you know just about like like he had the
thing about the liberal media
you know the media itself 90 of it is
negative news it's like what
like can you give us some hope talking
about how
the governor of florida
the governor of florida is into science
that he was into reading about covid in
the research and he did
he did research about it that he he
wanted to know the science
and so that's why he was really strict
about taking care of the elderly
in florida my girl's grandma lives in
florida
and they had strict restrict like she
was locked down in her
um facility that she was in in her you
know
independent living elderly folk elderly
home
for home for elderly people you know it
was they were really strict because the
governor there was like now we
this is affecting older people so we
have to make sure they're okay
you know i mean but because he's
republican
you know all the you know the liberal
that oh he's terrible he's doing
everything wrong
but now you look at what's happening
maybe he wasn't doing everything wrong
you know maybe a little bit maybe some
of the things he was doing and some of
the things people say california was
doing maybe they should have
communicated with each other and like
it figured out a better plan for all of
us so
i don't know once it's politicized then
it becomes like you verse them
you know so you know eventually
hopefully
history we'll be able to look back and
be like ooh i wish we we didn't do this
right
i feel like we're going to say that
anyway i feel like in 10 years we're
going to look back and all the reports
are going to come out
when all the politics is away from it
people are going to be like
we messed that up
but we're living through it we're trying
to live through it
let me see where i'm at all right well
we're almost uh
coming to an end here uh oh
well you know you know what i gotta
finish off with falcon in the winter
soldier my weekly update
spoiler alert at this point so now you
can just stop the podcast if you want
you know because if you haven't watched
episode 5
so spoiler alert but it was so good like
like this i j and this is just me
you know like i think that there was a
good percentage of
sort of social issues in this episode
but i thought it served the story so
there's this old black
super soldier that they had in jail and
they experimented on them
and then and then they had this idea
about you know
the falcons sam you know how steve
rogers gave him the shield and could
there be a black man as captain america
and it sort of was you know dealing with
those issues and how
you know it's that same old thing
that you sometimes you get tired of
hearing about and so
i know that there could be people out
there who are like watching this episode
like here we go
black people complaining about stuff you
know
um i you know what that's fair and i and
i can see how you might
feel that way but me personally because
i feel that way too
like sometimes when i watch things i go
can i just keep be entertained
i just want to be entertained sometimes
i don't want to like not everything has
to be woke
you know what i mean i just that's just
and i think that that's a fair feeling
like i want to escape from wokeness and
there's the other side of people who
feel like
well that's why it still continues and
if we don't bang the drum
okay so i i feel you but i'm all these
people i feel like i'm woke enough
i feel like i i understand i can have
empathy and also want to like
take a break you know but some people
feel like there should be no breaks so i
get both
sides of that but this episode i felt
like to me
it was a good portion because it served
the story
but it just was it's just really good
the
the dramatic part of it and anthony
mackie i believe is his name the guy
that plays the
the falcon this dude is in everything
man you go on netflix
he must be in like 10 netflix projects
good for him
the only thing i wish he would do is
change his look because like
he just he has such a distinct
look that it's always he's always that
so every time you see him it's that so
like he don't change his hair
you know what i mean he don't change his
like mannerisms it's like he
is anthony mackie that's his name right
yeah
you know he he's always that
so sometimes i wish he would change it
up get an afro do some you know what i
mean
but he works a lot but he is great
he's just he's just a moral compass in
uh
um falcon and winter soldier he just
you know you know what i mean we're
we're following him and we're seeing him
like having to make these choices about
who's right and who's wrong and and once
again sebastian stan is just playing uh
just what he's doing at the as the
winter soldier is just great
like it's such a great redemption story
he's like the darth vader
of this story you know he was this evil
menacing murderous character he killed
tony stark's
parents for god's sakes you know what i
mean even though he was being controlled
and just like
still it's that's the thing that's the
how they let him off the hook where it's
like it wasn't really him
and he's kind of an [ __ ] now he's got
this soft sweet side and he's just
he's just doing an amazing job
portraying
what's going on so you know i think the
show's coming to a hill and then you
know
the guy that's playing like this captain
america
you know so he like now he's the villain
you know but he always had villain face
you know what i mean so but now he's
gonna be the villain
and then they brought in uh uh what's
her face from seinfeld you know
louise strife what's her name um oh my
god
elaine from seinfeld she's such a great
actress
she comes in a place that's like like
like cd boss
character she comes in and she's trying
to recruit you know the old captain
america this new captain america guy
you know because now he's a super
soldier and you know you know and of
course
you know that's one of those great moral
dilemmas because he killed a guy that
killed his friend
and so there are people who feel like
eye for an eye so there's people that
would look at that and be like yeah that
guy had to die he killed his friend and
he went to the parents like
i got justice for your kid but then
there's the other side of it too where
people are like
dude you're supposed to be captain
america you're supposed to be
above reproach you're supposed to be you
know
a guy that wouldn't make that choice he
would make the hard choice he wouldn't
go with his impulses
and and do something like that he would
take that guy to justice that's what we
want
captain america to stand for and he
broke that oath
you know it's oh man
and then it's like it just brings to
light the corruption of government
because
and and how we don't
trust the government and in our
entertainment
we perpetuate that feeling because
you know it's like you go back i
remember when i was a boy
and i first saw superman with
christopher reeves
and i remember he said in the movie
you know what are you you know lois
lane's interviewing superman and she's
like what do you stand for and he was
like
truth justice and the american way
and i remember everybody in the theater
was like yeah and it meant something
back then
the american way meant something and it
meant
those things truth justice for all
equality it meant these things right cut
to now
they made superman again and they took
that out
because now what is the american way
what do people think that is
what do people think that means does it
mean corruption now
does it mean you know inequality does it
mean
sexism racism does it mean like to only
the rich you know so
we we have lost our way we've lost our
way we've lost
the understanding of who we are are we
good people
in all of our movies everything in the
movies now
it perpetuates this idea that we can't
trust the government
that that being in the united states
doesn't mean something good anymore
and i wish we could get back to
finding our way finding out
who we are and what kind of people do we
want to be
what kind of nation do we want to be do
we want to be equal do we want to love
everyone do we want to make sure our
women are being taken care of and
supported and held up high
that all races and people of different
genders
people of different sexual orientations
do we want
to make sure everyone is like looked
after and accounted for does america
stand for that anymore
i don't know you tell me in the comments
so if you have some feelings about that
let me know
because i feel like we're like divided
and
anyway i'm just saying i feel like
we don't have the same ra raw feeling
and i feel like we should
i feel like we are still a great nation
we got some issues and some problems but
damn i wouldn't want to be any place
else you wouldn't want to be any place
else
so hopefully we can uh get back to
what's right
but anyways um i think that's man i
didn't really
wow i really went in right here on my uh
episode
so guys thanks for listening to uh
roofing with griffin thanks for watching
sorry about the quality it is what it is
you know what i mean i'm i'm here in a
hotel trying to make this happen for
y'all
so make sure you um
[Music]
you know share subscribe check me out
here griffin gaiman
and uh again keep your fingers crossed
that michelle bucktown gets picked up
and
uh you know i'll keep you posted next
week i'll still be in new york so i'll
do another episode of new york hopefully
i can snag one of these guys to be a
guest
and you know we'll see uh what we can do
and i appreciate you guys being here and
supporting
and i will see you next week
you